supermodel linda evangelista is
demanding 50 million after she claims
she was permanently disfigured by a
popular cosmetic procedure
am i exaggerating if i call that a
deformity for the first time we see
those deformities a large bulging area
under both her arm and her chin the 56
year old shows people out friday what
she says is a side effect of
coolsculpting which led her to become a
recluse
considered a non-invasive lipo
alternative the procedure is supposed to
freeze fat cells to clear them from the
body but linda claims her fat deposits
grew and hardened in general i don't run
away i think the perfect figure is very
imperfect
et's been with linda throughout her
career from the runway to commercials
but in court documents we obtained linda
claims she's been unable to work since
2016 even after getting corrective full
body lipo twice at a cost of 38 thousand
dollars
with that sticking up of my body
linda accuses coolsculpting's parent
company celtic of failing to adequately
warn of serious adverse effects celtic
denies that citing rare side effects are
well documented in information provided
to patients
in her new interview linda tearfully
reflects how her changed mental state
affected the bond with augie her son
from a previous relationship with salma
hayek's now husband francois henri
pinault mommy do you remember when you
used to be fun i hate what this has done
to my relationship with him
[Music]
you